foreign
you will never be able to escape from
your heart so it's better to listen to
what it has to say
Every Blessing ignored becomes a curse
everyone seems to have a clear idea of
how other people should lead their lives
but none about his or her own
love never keeps a man from pursuing his
destiny
[Music]
never stop dreaming
[Music]
when I had nothing to lose I had
everything
when I stopped being who I am I found
myself
[Music]
nothing in the world is ever completely
wrong even a stopped clock is right
twice a day
foreign
things are also the most extraordinary
things and only the wise can see them
[Music]
all you have to do is pay attention
lessons always arrive when you are ready
when we strive to become better than we
are everything around us becomes better
too
never explain your friends won't need it
and haters will continue to hate
because they also hate themselves
when you repeat a mistake it is not a
mistake anymore it is a decision
[Music]
when someone leaves it's because someone
else is about to arrive
[Music]
what do you decide to do make sure it
makes you happy
[Music]
be brave take risks nothing can
substitute experience
[Music]
I can choose either to be a victim of
the world or an adventurer in search of
treasure it's all a question of how I
view my life
[Music]
the secret of life is to fall seven
times and to get up eight times
you are what you believe yourself to be
[Music]
happiness is something that multiplies
when it is divided
don't waste your time with explanations
people only hear what they want to hear
the more violent the storm the quicker
it passes
[Music]
now that she had nothing to lose she was
free
none of us knows what might happen in
the next minute yet we still go forward
because we trust because we have faith
fortunate are those who take the first
steps
the act of discovering who we are will
force us to accept that we can go
further than we think
[Music]
if you're brave enough to Say Goodbye
Life will reward you with a new hello
if you think Adventure is dangerous try
routine
that's lethal
live truly and forgive quickly
life is too short or too long for me to
allow myself the luxury of living it so
badly
[Music]
Life as a way of testing a person's will
either by having nothing happen at all
or by having everything happen at once
certain things in life have to be
experienced and never explained love is
such a thing
[Music]
when you are enthusiastic about what you
do
you feel this positive energy
it is very simple
stay mad but behave like normal people
run the risk of being different but
learn to do so without attracting
attention
if you start by promising what you don't
yet have you'll lose your desire to work
towards getting it
life always waits for some crisis to
occur before revealing itself at its
most brilliant
intuition is really a sudden immersion
of the Soul into the universal current
of life
a life without cause is a life without
effect
if you want to be successful you must
respect one rule never lie to yourself
don't give in to your fears if you do
you won't be able to talk to your heart
[Music]
if I am really a part of your dream
you'll come back one day
Miracles only happen if you believe in
miracles
[Music]
keeping passion at Bay or surrendering
blindly to it which of these two
attitudes is the least destructive I
don't know
[Music]
remember your dreams and fight for them
you must know what you want from life
people are capable at any time in their
lives of doing what they dream of
[Music]
there is just one thing that makes your
dream become impossible the fear of
failure
[Music]
you drown not by falling into a river
but by staying submerged in it
[Music]
tears are words that need to be written
[Music]
why is patience so important
because it makes us pay attention
[Music]
people never learn anything by being
told they have to find out for
themselves
one day you will wake up and there won't
be any more time to do the things you've
always wanted to do
do them now
if someone is always on your mind it
means you are in love or you are owed a
large amount
the strongest love is the love that can
demonstrate its fragility
[Music]
anyone who loves in the expectation of
being loved in return is wasting their
time
I've learned that waiting is the most
difficult bit
and I went to get used to the feeling
knowing that you're with me even when
you're not by my side
don't allow your mind to tell your heart
what to do
the Mind gives up easily
[Music]